alors partout autour de la planète soyez
là où la bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale de tam-tam canada en direct du
salon du développement canado maghrébins
qui se déroule ici au palais des congrès
de montréal donc au coeur de la ville de
montréal et ce pendant deux jours les 8
et 9 septembre alors c'est un événement
important c'est la troisième fois qu'on
a monté ce salon qui s'adresse d'abord
et avant tout à des professionnels de la
communauté du maghreb ici au canada et
avec vous autour y autour data vous avez
sept autres personnes incluant moi même
stéphane parent l'animateur mais sept
autres personnes de la communauté des
gens qui sont nés ici des gens qui sont
arrivés ici des gens qui ont permis à
cette communauté de bondir en nombre et
on l'espère un jour de bondir en
influence encore davantage au sein de
cette société québécoise qui les
accueillent
on va essayer de comprendre les enjeux
certains des enjeux qui se dressent
devant cette communauté mais d'abord
question protocolaires mais aussi amical
on à abel achouri qui est avec nous ici
c'est le responsable du salon
l'organisateur et je voulais vous
demander ce que vous comptez accomplir
en cette troisième édition c'est votre
troisième cool comme un match de tennis
l'avouer c'est encore une fois de
d'accomplir un travail important durant
ces deux jours qu'est ce que c'est
exactement
tout d'abord j'aimerais te remercier
stéphane pour cette belle initiative
d'organiser une émission à partir du
salon du développement canada marie va
même je reviendrai rapidement à ta
question pour te dire en fait commencé
né cet événement cet événement là est
née de notre volonté à promouvoir les
intérêts de notre communauté à
repositionner notre communauté
par rapport aux ici au québec puis au
niveau du canada ce qu'on aimerait faire
notre mission déjà par rapport à ce
salon là c'est c'est le développement de
la commune et de la communauté
maghrébine
qu'est ce qu'on voudrait avoir en voudra
voir des jeunes on voudrait avoir des
quatre qui soit au niveau des têtes à
haut revenu à la tête des organisations
québécoises et canadiennes des jeunes en
politique c'est ce que j'ai dit on
voudrait avoir notre
notre rôle un rôle important au sein de
la communauté canadienne et québécoise
c'est dans ce sens là que s'intègre cet
événement là on est en train d'
impliquer pas mal de personnes pas mal
d'associations avec nous et c'est dans
ce sens là que on vous inviter à cet
événement là pour que vous puissiez voir
les gens poser des questions comprendre
c'est quoi notre réalité à travers des
gens qui je pense d'abord je voudrais
parler un tout petit peu par rapport à
comment ce qu'on a fait pour choisir ces
gens là alors pendant que vous vous
recueillez ses idées je me tourne vers
mon technicien chef les eaux
il va mettre une vidéo que seuls nos
internautes vont pouvoir voir mais ça va
les aider à comprendre l'importance du
salon ce sont des images qu'on a
confectionné on est expert là dedans
petite vidéo de je pense le milieu de 30
à peu près voilà on est prêt ça vous
montre ce salon à quoi ça ressemble
lorsqu'il roule à plein régime comme
pratiquement en ce moment et donc vous
avez pour revenir à ce que vous disiez
vous avez décidé de nous aider à
sélectionner des personnes dans la
communauté qui ne sont pas
nécessairement les plus connus mais qui
mérite d'être découvert un peu ce que
vous voulez faire accord avec tout le
reste de la communauté à faire découvrir
oui en fait est ce que ce qu'on a essayé
de faire c'est de de mettre en valeur
des personnes qui selon nous représente
la communauté maghrébine
parce qu'il faut pas l'oublier comme
toute autre communauté nous sommes une
communauté hétérogènes
nous ne sont pas homogènes et chercher
des gens qui représentent la majorité ou
qui représentent des groupes au niveau
de la communauté
ça permet à tous les spectateurs
maghrébins qui regarde qui entendent la
radio de se sentir un petit peu
représenté dans ce pays là et ça va les
amener à se sentir québécois se sentir
canadien a développé ce sentiment
d'appartenance et d'inclusion et c'est
réellement l'objectif de notre salon
alors on va retenir ce mot tous ensemble
ici autour de la table inclusion on
repart avec sa note quelques secondes
merci beaucoup à dell on vous laisse
filer vous avez d'autres choses à
organiser sinon tout tomberait
j'en suis sûr alors autour de la table
nos invités aujourd'hui j'ai fait de la
ségrégation mais ces deux labels
ségrégation j'ai mis les filles d'un
côté les gars de l'autre c'est plus
facile pour point de mire trouvait alors
nous avons un sit in à ces petits qui
est également une des organisatrice du
salon et qui est une femme plutôt
formidable qui porte plusieurs chapeaux
qui verse dans la politique municipale
m'avait étonné j'espère que les gens
vont vous découvrir au cours des
prochaines minutes même si le temps qui
nous est alloué
chacun d'entre nous à l'exception de moi
même et ré est pas très important merci
nous avons également myriam bouzaiene
qui bonjour qui sera essentiel dans nos
conversations sur la discrimination
également sur les questions de des
médias de la création de ces médias plus
puissants ici qui représenterait la
communauté et une présence plus forte de
cette communauté à travers nos médias
ici traditionnel également nous avons
une jeune fille jeune dame
aujourd'hui on dit plus je ne fais je
sais plus 21 ans et qui est une
ambassadrice ambassadrice de la ville de
montréal et qui a remporté un concours
c'était 200 400 personnes oudart achoui
qui était qui ont postulé pour l'emploi
d'ambassadrice de la ville de montréal
pardon des 100 personnes de simple il
faut parler plus fort des 100 personnes
c'est tellement beau donc 200 personnes
et on va découvrir avec vous ce que le
message que vous essayez de transmettre
aux autres à la jeune génération c'est
très important et on va se tourner
maintenant vers les plus vieux on
commence par il a à peine 28 ans alors
il s'agit de mohamed garrett mohamed il
est il verse dans la politique qui est
un activiste politique
il aime beaucoup les activités
politiques est également un grand
diplomate
il sera peut-être un de nos futurs
diplomates on voit le voir et également
à côté de lui c'est une sommité c'est
quelqu'un qui va écouter vous mais
pression' et parce que vous avez
organisé pas mal de choses jusqu'à
maintenant et il s'agit de monsieur
abdeladim el habchi qui aujourd'hui on
se limitera à ce seul site pour le
moment est le grand patron d'une station
de
télévision may be tv qui a un stand ici
et qui fait plus que mettre des stades
visités véritable émission puis on va
montrer une vidéo un peu plus tard de
ceux de vos activités
et puis on va aussi maintenant commencer
la conversation autour de l'inclusion
si vous le permettez avec un journée
c'est un collègue il s'agit de abd el
ghany tadesse bonjour monsieur d'hadès
bonjour vous allez mettre la table pour
nous cette communauté montrions à quel
point elle est grande elle est devenue
grande depuis 20 ans depuis 20 ans
depuis un peu plus de 20 ans il ya eu
par les plus forts en 1994-95 le maghreb
a été retenu comme bassin principal
l'immigration francophone au québec à
partir de cette date a explosé ce
qu'avant on avait bon à part le cas
particulier des algériens qui étaient
réfugiés pour des raisons que l'on
connaît tous il y avait entre 3000 4000
arrivées par an nouveaux arrivants pas
partir du moment où le maghreb est
devenu bassin principal l'immigration
francophone on a commencé à dépasser les
dix mille imaginé depuis 95 avec des
pointes à partir des années 2000 du
début des années 2000 a va 25 mille
nouveaux arrivants voire 35 milles c'est
à dire grosso modo 80% des nouvelles
arrivées
on est aujourd'hui autour de 350 milles
mais à un très grand flou taux de ces
statistiques en fait selon les sources
on arrive à 150 milles à 350 milles
s'ils vous rendez dans les consulats des
pays maghrébins où on comptabilise
uniquement les antilles sans registre on
arrive aux alentours de 180 m le tout le
tout le magasin
est-ce que ça inclut les jeunes qui sont
nés au canada pour certains oui ceux qui
sont inscrits dans le sur les registres
consulaires mais en général dans les
statistiques les nés au canada ne sont
pas comptabilisés comme
en plus les statistiques fédérales par
exemple on retient comme maghrébins
celui qui se reconnaît maghrébins les
malgré les originaires du maghreb qui
viennent de france ou de belgique sont
d'abord français ou belge est donc là
vous voyez un petit peu mais on peut
estimer
c'est un travail que j'avais fait le
conseil des relations interculturelles
du québec donc le système qu'on a mis en
place restent valables
on peut raisonnablement estimer notre
nombre à 350 milles aujourd'hui canada
costumes postes canada qu'aux causes et
ce qui est particulier c'est le nombre
de francophones 83 cents à 85 % et 5 %
le taux de diplomation intérieur cette
communauté les évolutions socio
démographique de cette communauté par
exemple que les premiers arrivants sont
diplômés à 90 ou 95 % les générations
suivantes beaucoup moins écouté la
médicalisation les premiers arrivés
étaient surmédicalisées ici malgré la
gratuité des soins ils ne sont un petit
peu moins
donc là je fais exprès d'aborder les
aspects négatifs pour entrer déjà sur la
première tête mathématique celle de la
discrimination c'est très bien mais très
vous êtes un professionnel
on le sent le voiture une charnière
gratuitement on a d'autres
professionnels ici des médias et myriam
qui travaillent à ses 185
ouais alors écoutez 106 points
on va parler des médias un peu plus tard
le sont les deux côtés on en parle trop
de toute façon mes blagues à part la
discrimination systémique pourquoi ce
mot systémique
c'est dans le discours politique
maintenant c'est inscrit officiellement
depuis juillet la ministre des
migrations du québec qui a décidé de
faire une petite enquête ou demander à
la commission des droits de la personne
du québec d'être le maître d'oeuvre de
cette enquête
certains ont dit faudrait plus qu'une
enquête soit une commission denquête
parce que le problème est plus sérieux
que certains voudraient l'admettre alors
soyons selon au clair moi j'ai déjà été
victime de discrimination parce que je
teint plus foncé que j'allais dans
d'autres régions du monde où tout le
monde était clair
mais autour de la table au niveau de la
discrimination
soyez honnête est-ce que ce que vous
pouvez dire que vous rencontrez encore
aujourd'hui les exemples très clair où
il ya discrimination à votre égard en
raison de votre nom de votre accent ou
de ce qu'on perçoit de vos origines
lever la main si quelqu'un peut dire oui
à sa personne je peux dire oui et non
alors le nom parce que c'est pas affiché
c'est pas le voisin qui est juste à côté
où le patron au travail ou la personne
qui va rencontrer pour un recrutement
qui va te dire qu'il qu'il applique
cette discrimination mais il est
ressenti
on la voit on la constate à travers par
exemple je prendrai l'exemple de
l'employabilité
d'accord ça je peux en parler parce
qu'on peut trouver qu'il ya une
discrimination à travers le nom savez
tout simplement que tu t'appelles
mohamed abdel quelque chose comme ça ou
bien le greeter des gestes facilement et
ça ce n'est pas des statistiques réelles
c'est ça la problématique mais à travers
les gens que j'ai rencontrés qu'on m'a
parlé et où on constate ça donc ça c'est
un constat qui existe puis ça ça se
démontre aussi au niveau 2 comme j'ai
dit dès le clic mans mais même au niveau
de passation dont des postes de
responsabilité à travers d'autres
entreprises
donc c'est quelque chose qui existe mais
qui n'est pas apparente qui n'est pas
affichée je voudrais que mon technicien
léonie montre cette vidéo que seuls les
internautes peuvent voir mais je peux
vous traduire cent mille mots c'est une
image essentiellement ça montre le taux
de chômage parmi les nouveaux arrivants
ici au québec comparé à montréal que
comparé à d'autres grandes villes
canadiennes et on découvre que il est
plus élevé à montréal est est ce que ça
veut dire que le travail est ce qu'il
faut je me tourne vers les films parce
que vous avez su mais on en parle et les
gars alors du côté des filles lever la
main est ce que ça veut dire que le
travail semble plus s'annonce plus
difficile ici au québec des fois si je
peux me permettre
en fait
personnellement je suis arrivé à l'âge
de deux ans à montréal donc je n'ai pas
vécu de discrimination systémique
pourtant mon prénom mon vrai prénom dans
les papiers tin hinan et non pas de tina
tuner est un surnom
mais peut-être par le fait que j'ai
étudié ici j'ai travaillé ici très jeune
je n'ai jamais eu ou rencontrer
d'obstacles vraiment par contre autour
de moi mes amis ont vécu cette
discrimination parce que leur prénom
leur nom de famille était
semblait maghrébin arabe bien qu'ils
aient graduée pourtant d'universités
québécoises
donc oui ça existe et même s'ils passent
des examens par exemple j'ai en tête un
ami qui est actuaire qui pourtant
n'avaient pas bougé de l'entreprise ou
et les parce qu'il a eu sa chance à cet
endroit
et lorsqu'il dépose ailleurs ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que les cv sont mis
de côté c'est ça oui je pense que myriam
vous pourriez ajouter ensuite moi
j'aimerais rajouter stéphane bon je ne
parlerai pas de mon expérience
personnelle mais plutôt des statistiques
puis de mon entourage comme tina moi
j'ai un ami qui fait une équipe et un
doctorat en sociologie puis fait une
étude sur hubert le chauffeur hubert
puis il a remarqué que justement parmi
la communauté maghrébine parce que lui
fait des entrevues quand il monte dans
un hubert il demande aux gens puis l'a
remarqué que beaucoup de gens diplômés
parmi la communauté maghrébine qui font
ça donc ça c'est un indicateur selon moi
que justement il ya des difficultés
réelles surtout quand on est diplômé
francophones à transférer les
compétences dans être médecin ou
peut-être médecin c'est compliqué choisi
le mauvais mes ingénieurs
il ya une grande difficulté quand on
arrive ici avec une famille des enfants
un besoin criant de subvenir aux besoins
de la famille puis à un moment donné on
se retrouve à faire n'importe quoi dans
ce qui ce qui s'offre à nous puis on
plonge dans sa sans pouvoir en sortir
c'est sale je voudrais vous poser la
question villa mais encore une fois je
mens je peux pas lire dans vos pensées
sont éloquentes mais on entendra pas
qu'ils me qui sera en faveur ici que les
cv qui sont envoyées au gouvernement ou
dans les entreprises que la loi disent
il faut pas voir les noms il faut que
vous sélectionnez à partir des critères
de la personne déclarée les qu'elle a
fait est là tel diplôme 9 10 des cv
anonymes
le fédéral a un projet en ce sens je
sais que ça se discute au québec qui est
en faveur de sa ou pas levé la main oui
je suis en faveur parce qu'en fait la
première chose qu'on vende ans à cvc le
nom et prénom
fait ça affecte le contenu du cv
donc on se passe vraiment pas sur l'
expertise ou où les études ou et c'est
parce que je connais du monde qui ont
changé leur nom de famille à cause de ça
puis après l'employeur avait découvert
que y était maghrébin malgré son nom de
famille mais après ça il ya perdu son
travail à l'est vraiment très c'est plus
que triste je peux être pas d'accord
tout à fait parce qu'en france on a fait
la même chose mais ça n'a pas résolu le
problème parce que une fois que tu es
devant le recruteur à ils ont fait ce
qu'il veut parce que c'est là où il ya
la discrimination à l'avant là dedans
donc ça veut dire le changement de nom
ça va rien changer
le fait de cacher parce que même
quelqu'un qui vient du maghreb il va
venir on va savoir où il a étudié
maintenant avec tout ce qui est réseaux
sociaux on may et puis on peut savoir où
se trouve l'université tout donc je
pense qu'il doit y avoir un changement
de mains d'un changement de penser que
les gens pensent que ces gens là qui
vient et je pense ce film est une phobie
qui s'est créé à travers le 11 septembre
2001 donc que les gens ont commencé à
avoir peur de ça et puis donc de
détecter ces maghrébins
je sais pas quoi d'accord alors si on
veut comme ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
comme à des adeptes si on peut faire le
phare sur les personnalités qui sont ici
qui ont forgé le canada qui sont dans la
recherche qui sont dans dans les
finances qui sont dans plusieurs
domaines mais qui ne sont pas connus et
là je pense qu'un rôle de média
monsieur d'hadès je crois pas que le cv
anonyme
puisse régler le problème c'est les
causes sont tellement diverse et
multiple pour une deuxième pour cette
exclusion qu'il faut peut-être revenir
un petit peu en arrière c'est le moment
clé dans le discours sur la
discrimination en matière d'accès à
l'emploi
c'est 2004 le jour on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait un taux de chômage
communauté maghrébine de l'ordre de 28%
27 8% qui était vraiment le record par
rapport à l'époque à 8% pour la
communauté la plus anciennement arrivée
et elle était suivie par la communauté
noire originaire d'afrique
s'il ya plusieurs communautés noires au
québec on le sait suivi de la communauté
noire suit évidemment des asiatiques et
des communautés et ce à partir du moment
qu'on a commencé à se rendre compte que
la question du cv anonyme des procédures
et cetera n'était pas suffisant il
fallait vraiment une d'abord une volonté
politique la volonté politique affirmée
et une action politique conséquente
la preuve que cette prise de conscience
a donné des résultats et que c'était la
bonne méthode c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans
la communauté maghrébine qui reste
champion du québec toutes catégories
avec
18 6% de taux de chômage malgré tout
qualification et diplomation plus élevé
que la moyenne nationale dit en passant
que les politiques menées entre 2004 et
2010 est en donner quelques résultats
c'est évidemment pas satisfaisant je
veux je venais à cet ennemi % contre 18
%
un gap de 11 et demi ça veut dire qu'un
mannequin originaire du maghreb un deux
fois et demie plus de chance d'être au
chômage que n'importe quel lequel de ses
concitoyens mais la première fait que
une volonté politique
une des actions politiques des actions
de terrain auprès des employeurs dans
l'opinion publique pouvait donner des
résultats que c'est la voie sûre que
c'est ça qu'il faut continuer de faire
c'est de continuer à mettre l'accent sur
des politiques pratiques concrets je
vais de rester dans le domaine des
statistiques que vous avez bien lancée
on va regarder la vidéo numéro 3 je
parle ici des internautes nous on doit
se fier à ma mémoire mais j'ai quand
même ici un petit rappel
et cette vidéo montre les liens entre
les préjugés et les immigrants qui
accèdent à des postes de cadres et là je
pense que c'est un dossier qui devrait
intéresser beaucoup les gens autour de
la table parce que les cadres ont dit
c'est les chefs d'entreprise ce et des
responsables d'entreprises mais c'est
aussi des leaders très souvent au sein
des communautés
c'est des gens capables de prendre en
tout cas des décisions de faciliter la
croissance du reste de la communauté au
sein de ces entreprises
s'il ya déjà quelqu'un si adele est déjà
arrivé à l'entreprise peut-être qu'il
peut convaincre son patron que mohamed
aussi pourrait lui apporter
c'est comme ça que fonctionne on n'est
pas en france là mais les contacts ces
précieux ici quand même hein alors on
voit sur cette vidéo que le principal
handicap au québec à montréal ce sont
des chiffres de montréal au niveau de
l'ascension débat des postes de cadres
des immigrants c'est la maîtrise du
français
une fois sur cinq c'est le gros problème
c'est pas votre problème
ensuite 10 % c'est l'anglais bon
peut-être que c'est un problème est là
bon c'est un tien
du problème c'est linguistique mais est
ce que c'est vraiment ça j'aurais plutôt
tendance à dire que c'est culturel mais
quand on connaît pas son voisin et est
ce que vos voisins vous connaissent
c'est une question très simple
est-ce que vos voisins vous connaissent
qu'est ce qu'ils connaissent de vous
c'est une autre question mais est-ce qui
vous connaissent ceux qui le connaissent
peut-être que si on travaille fort à
développer son réseau et à aller vers
eux
ils commencent à nous connaître
peut-être que la curiosité de leur part
est encore très timide venir vers nous
et en apprendre davantage je pense pas
qu'il y ait grand chose de nous mais
peut-être plus en plus si on s'implique
davantage que ce soit dans l'épaule au
niveau de la politique au niveau des
médias accéder rappel être de se faire
voir d'avoir des noms un peu médiatisé
vous non pas ça va faire en sorte que ça
se retrouver dans leur salon et je pense
que c'est ça on peut toujours dire il ya
un problème il est là le problème devant
nous il faut il ya un travail
d'introspection à faire à chaque fois
dans ce match dans toutes les choses de
la vie il faut se regarder quand on veut
critiquer alors regardons nous ou
regardez vous au niveau des médias
vous êtes une jeune communauté vous avez
on va montrer cette vidéo numéro 4 voir
le dynamisme des ja qui existe à la
radio myriam vous travaillez dans une de
ces radios et ces jeunes c'est avec les
moyens du bord zac te ment donc c'est
aussi beaucoup d'obstacles travailler
dans la radio communautaire il faut être
dans le milieu communautaire il faut
être passionné
il faut donner de son temps il faut
donner
il faut prendre du temps sur sa famille
mais
c'est vraiment pour la communauté que
les gens qui travaillent dans ce domaine
là c'est vraiment pour la communauté
d'abord c'est au sein de la communauté
pour les sortir de leur torpeur
hivernale souvent il ya beaucoup
d'immigrants qui arrivent ici avec des
enfants il n'y a pas de famille qui
aident famille directe donc souvent
beaucoup de femmes sont à la maison donc
ouvrir la radio c'est le commentaire qui
revient souvent donc ça ça enlève un
petit peu de nostalgie de 2
de mal de du pays surtout les premières
années on s'entend que après moi je dis
après cinq années ça commence on
commence à être plus québécois que mais
je pense que les statistiques aussi le
disent après cinq ans on commence à être
plus fonctionnel sur le milieu du
travail je ne connais pas les
statistiques exactes mais ça s'améliore
beaucoup
maintenant quand on arrive on a beaucoup
d'espoir et de et d'attentes
on attend beaucoup de son pays d'accueil
puis on se bute aussi à beaucoup
d'obstacles
on découvre la réalité exactement c'est
le rêve est exactement exactement donc
les médias communautaires sont là pour
faciliter d'abord cette intégration et
faire le pont entre ces immigrants qui
sont chez eux ils sont peut-être cloître
et c'est l'hiver il ya deux mètres de
neige est là la réalité l'actualité du
québec
il n'a lui pas forcément la télé sur
leur fil d'actualité facebook qui n'ont
peut-être pas radio-canada encore oui
ils ignorent l'existence donc les
intégrer petit à petit dans ces choses
là en parlant en les incitant les
chercher en parlant de leurs problèmes
en écoutant leurs problèmes justement
c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas de solution mais
c'est quand même oui il ya des la dîme
and chic est avec nous qui est le grand
patron de may be tv et moi je suis pas
allé mais j'ai regardé une partie de
votre production ces professionnels
lancé c'est épatant mais vous pensez
qu'il faut relancer les choses il faut
ça à peine deux ans comme expérience
exactement désendettement alors comment
reposer sur les choses là par rapport
aux médias communautaires juifs à quand
je suis là dedans mais on ne doit pas
rester dans nos ghettos
parce que le problème de média social
média communautaire ça ne laisse entre
marocains entre algérie entre tous
pourquoi ne pas s'ouvrir à la diversité
et nous je parle je parle de la
diversité global ça veut dire si et là
on vous remercie pour cette initiative
si les radios des télévisions d'ici ne
nous donne pas la possibilité de parler
on va créer des radios des télévisions
dont on va parler on va inviter les
canadiens les québécois de débattre avec
nous parce que le crâne aux antilles que
nous avons avec les médias c'est que il
ya des td td liste à chaque fois qu'on
fait appel à eux
si un problème par rapport à l'islamisme
on va chercher la personne qui va aller
chercher le taux d'audience le plus
élevé malgré que cette personne ne
représentent qu'elles mêmes qui est seul
mais parce que son nom est connu par les
médias on va faire appel
par contre il ya d'autres personnes
qu'on va faire appel notre rôle dans ce
média l'un de la diversité c'est là le
changement parce que la télévision était
marocaine au début maintenant et les
plus diversifiées et les plus même dont
l'équipe technique nous avons des
latinos des français des marocains des
débats neto donc c'est même dans
l'équipe qui est là dedans et puis aller
vers cette diversité et s'ouvrir à tout
le monde
cette ouverture va nous permettre aux
quais comme la question que vous a dit
que les autres vont nous reconnaître
d'accord je pense que moi mes gars du
seriez d'accord avec ça parce que vous
pourriez être un de ses talents qu'on
développe pour vous en parler assez
longuement téléphone c'est vous êtes un
diplomate jeu mais ça restait un petit
peu dans la paix n'ont pas trop vous
affichez mais vous pourriez prendre la
parole et et ses médias s'ils s'il avait
une stratégie peu moins communautaire
est un peu plus
global it erp pour utiliser un terrible
mollahs ça permettrait de développer des
nouvelles voies et de monsieur delà des
120 avez vous tout de suite après merci
aux débuts de m'avoir donné
l'opportunité de m'exprimer ici avec
vous je vais retourner un peu sur le
sujet du racisme
écoutez le racisme existe mais il faut
pas démoraliser les portes les
opportunités aussi existent si un bon cv
ne suffit pas un excellent cv pourra
suffire
je connais quelques j'ai des amis je
connais je veux donner des exemples par
exemple j'ai un ami qui venue de la
tunisie il a passé ils étaient cadres en
informatique en tunisie pendant huit ans
il a essayé de trouver un travail
pendant une année et demie il a pas
trouvé il a pas laissé tomber
il a retourné aux études pour il a fait
un certificat il a il un très bon poste
je connais un autre qui qui a cueilli un
master en finance il a passé deux ans
dans un centre d'appels en même temps il
a fait des cours de soir après il a
réussi à avoir un poste un très bon
poste dans une banque
maintenant il est à l'international il a
réussi à avoir une carrière à
l'international comme je les dis je le
répète le racisme existe mais les
opportunités existent mais ça devra être
un défi de développement personnel au
niveau individuel mais aussi au niveau
de la communauté saran ça nous donne
écoutez chaque communauté chaque
première et deuxième génération en
immigration il se trouve au début dans
ce genre de problème ce qui qui qui ont
eu juste la chance de travailler en
construction il ya quelques décennies
aujourd'hui il y ce sont les chefs des
plus grandes entreprises de de
construction ici au canada
donc je dis toujours que il faut pas il
faut pas laisser tomber
il faut pas démoralisés mais il faut
prendre ça comme défi personnel avec le
développement personnel
si on lâche pas on va on va finir par
trouver un résultat et les médias voilà
au niveau des médias
écoutez les médias communautaires c'est
important mais c'est écouter juste par
les médias comparent en grande partie
par parallèle les communautés auxquelles
ils s'adressent
mais ici on a besoin de s'adresser à la
société canadienne
c'est si si on fait partie de cette
société ça veut dire en partagent leurs
soucis on fait partie des dialogues
participer participer exactement on fait
partie de cette communauté de cette
société ça veut dire en partage les
soucis ont particip ait aux six ans
participent dans les débats et dans dans
les débats et il faut construire
ensemble on parle ensemble on discute
ensemble et on s'adresse à toute la
société canadienne donc c'est important
de l'est comme je le dis et je le répète
les médias comme la terre c'est
important mais aussi il faut plus de
visibilité au niveau des médias
nationale je délaisse je voulais juste
tout le monde parle de médias
communautaires pour les médias des
communautés culturelles
c'est désagréable à dire mais on n'est
pas des médias communautaires aux yeux
du monde des médias canadiens québécois
on est des médias ethniques
c'est à dire qu'on est une espèce de
genre mineur qui réservait aux autres
qu'on ne lit pas ce qui est faux parce
que tout le monde lit je sais que parmi
mes mes contempteurs dans l'est certains
médias il y en a qui qui m'attaquent
parfois qu'ils savent parfaitement ce
que j'écris ce à dire qu'ils ont lu mes
faux semblants que non parce que je suis
médias ethniques médias communautaires
j'ai défendu cette idée que nous étions
des médias communautaires longtemps et
puis j'ai fini par comprendre que ça ne
servait à rien parce qu'il y à une
association de médias communautaires qui
subventionnait qui reçoit des
subventions qui ne souhaite absolument
pas les partager avec la partie la plus
dynamique des médias au corps pays
celle qui est dit quelque chose comme
400 titres de presse écrite qui a une
plusieurs que les visions numérique des
émissions ou des chaînes radio qui est
dans le numérique dans les nouveaux
médias qui est en train de prendre un
espace extraordinaire mais qu'il le fait
à ses propres frais sa propre charge
suis à l'aise si vous obtenez vous êtes
d'accord vous semblez dire que oui là
j'ai juste un petit détail pour revenir
sur ce que disait ma mère y les
communautés culturelles ont besoin
d'être sur les grands médias nationaux
il ya une expérience que nous
connaissons tous ça s'appelle la cité
qui est la seule qui est la seule à
avoir respecté une directive du crtc de
2003 deux mètres derrière l'écran et le
micro et devant l'écran et le micro la
diversité au premier plan
s'adresser à tous les médias canadiens
et tous tous les médias tous les grands
groupes ont créé en leur sein des
équipes de réflexion pour amener la
diversité il y en a au moins un que je
ne citerai pas qui m'a dit très
clairement auprès duquel j'ai travaillé
quelque temps qui m'a dit will tout ce
que tu dis est très bien et il s'était
parfaitement consciente du problème
ce que tu dis est très bien mais si je
l'appliqué que je perd 1% de taux
d'audience demain c'est notre
interlocuteur que tu as devant toi ce
sera plus moi alors dit moi ce que je
peux faire sans perdre de taux
d'audience ou six ans père auprès de ma
clientèle classique lancé bien pensants
vous en récupère au moins autant du côté
des gens dont tu en train de baisser
c'est un problème c'est vous les médias
au québec par exemple de parly 2 reste
du canada et à l'école et tous des coûts
de baisse alors c'est un problème que
nous avons en parler uniquement du
québec
ouais parler uniquement du québec pas du
reste du canada il est évident que lou s
c'est une autre montée mais c'est une
autre affaire je ne me reconnais pas
dans une télévision qui parlerait en
français qui traiterait de thématiques
de regrets d'accoître mais il semble
qu'au québec comme on a un point commun
qui est la langue française et la
francophonie
on devrait pouvoir faire de la diversité
francophone intelligente et
significative qui permettent justement
de surmonter un certain nombre
d'universités francophones et bien belle
plateforme sur laquelle travailler
lorsque ces vendeurs monsieur lannoy
alors pour mon opinion par rapport à
médias communautaires c'est
effectivement
je n'attaque personne parce que c'est
des gens qui sont en tête de plusieurs
plusieurs plusieurs entités mais le fait
que de faire une demande par exemple je
prendre pour la télévision pour faire
une demande la rdc le cahier des charges
est le même pour l'ensemble d'accord et
les dissidents en fin de compte ce sont
2 qui sans dont les autres médias donc
c'est pas évident de trouver sa place
par un père parce que il ya une manne
quelque part à partager même pour les
grands médias parce qu'il ya de l'argent
ailleurs qui se ramasse puis qui se
partagent à la fin puis est ce que
j'aurai ma pas non donc pour que puisse
avoir ma part il faut que je travaille
pendant cinq ans six ans avec mes
propres moyens après que je dois trouver
des gens qui doivent certifier ce que je
fais malgré que ce que j'ai fait est
suivi par des millions de personnes pour
que je puisse d'abord que monde et 6
soit déposée pour qu'il soit accepté ou
non à la fin ça c'est la même chose et
pour la télévision et pour la radio
c'est pour ça que kia ca pour l'été vise
pour les divisions communautaires c'est
la même chose qu'il ya des gens qui
derrière communautaire je sais qui a
cédé associations mais dans les
associations il ya des dix lecteurs il
ya des gens et des gens donc il ya de
l'argent quelque part
et puis nous on n'a pas de place dans
cet argent pour l'instant bien décrit le
problème c'est assez clair le 6 il ya
des gens qui écoutent ils ont entendu je
voulais vous demander
moi je suis dans les nouvelles
technologies mais j'ai pas de montre je
suis de génération qui en a pas est-ce
quelqu'un peut me dire si j'ai même pas
de téléphone civile a aujourd'hui est-ce
que quelle heure est il
15h38
donc il nous reste encore of 7 bonnes
minutes au moins
quel luxe je voulais je sais qu'on doit
parler de politique ensemble je pense
qu'on l'a fait déjà un peu je vais me
tourner vers notre jeune ambassadrice de
la ville de montréal qui est avec nous
et qui donc a remporté un concours
contre 200 autres candidats alors roues
d'un rachat louis dit nous être
ambassadrices
pour la ville de montréal mais pourquoi
exactement quel est le but et c'est un
but à long terme qui va s'étaler sur les
25 prochaines années
effectivement c'est c'est c'est un défi
qui va s'étaler sur 25 ans c'est à dire
dont le 400e anniversaire de montréal
mon défi c'était de rapprocher les
jeunes aux élus parce que je vois qu'il
ya un certain écart
il n'y a pas assez de communication
entre les jeunes et les élus
donc c'était ça le but du projet parce
qu'en fait les dix neuf ambassadeurs
qu'ils avaient pour but de ramener des
consultations auprès des jeunes des
écoles secondaires des collèges etc
puis je me suis dit que ça va être un
petit peu difficile au début mais après
ça j'avais visité deux écoles
secondaires
la première c'était entendre cet ex père
est dans mon arrondissement puis je me
suis dit peut-être qu'il va pas y avoir
assez d'interaction etc
mais au contraire je me suis aperçu que
il faut juste d'aborder les jeunes pour
qu'ils nous parlent l'horizon leurs
opinions ils ont leur mot à dire mais il
faut juste les approcher pour qu'ils
nous disent qu'est ce qui ressemble
vraiment qu'est ce que c'est montréal
pour eux qu'est ce qu'ils aimeraient
changer dans montréal c'est ça ouais
qu'elle est maintenant la tâche pour les
25 prochaines années est ce que c'est
une vraie comprendre vous êtes vous vous
questionnez ces jeunes ils vous livrent
leurs impressions leurs propos et s'est
mis de côté on va dire ça dans 25 ans
comme dans une capsule du temps non
c'est quoi en fait c'est un dépôt à la
ville de montréal qui a été fait au
dernier c'était 25 projets qui vont être
établi d'ici 25 ans ça rassemble
beaucoup de projets
une deux
politique pour et par les jeunes
développement durable économie beaucoup
des thématiques
c'est un des thèmes je pense qu'ils
sous-entendus dans ce dans ce salon
c'est c'est d'amener les jeunes à
s'intéresser à la question politique
peut-être qu'ils deviendront un jour des
leaders politiques il ya ou d'à peine 1
km 194 à 2014 a été si vous voulez la
plus la grande représentante celle qui
est con d'identifier venant de la
communauté maghrébine mais si vous
regardez là il ya des gens qui se
présentent aux élections et on en a vu
la dernière élection fédérale
mais il n'y a pas vous êtes quand même
300 me n'est plus avec un bon alors ça
va être assez du monde ça sur une
population québécoise de 7 millions donc
vous devriez avoir un certain nombre de
réussite au niveau politique
est ce que je sais pas ce que c'est
important juste une petite précision
quand on pense aux maghrébins on pense
uniquement maghrébin de confession
musulmane
on a eu d'autres députés d'origine
maghrébine au fédéral et dans certaines
provinces qui était d'origine maghrébine
et de confession juive donc houda pépin
n'est pas le seul exemple sur la
participation politique effectivement il
ya encore un gros effort à faire mais il
ya eu pas mal je parle pas du temps de
ce qui est le plus évident c'est à dire
le candidat mais dans les appareils
politiques qui en a quelques-uns quand
même y en a quelques-uns qui ont un
certain impact mais comme pour le reste
de de la citoyenneté assumer et accepter
de part et d'autre il ya une période de
latence qui expliquait mohamed a
toujours deux trois générations
sacrifiées
toutes les nouvelles et communauté tous
les flux migratoires nouveau dans
l'histoire du québec et du canada ont
une
une période de bizutage qui a pu durer
deux générations en trois générations et
c'est particulièrement sensible dans le
domaine dans des domaines comme les
médias ou la politique la gare où on a
fait suspicion systématique de la double
loyauté
ah oui et oui c'est intéressant et donc
qui nécessite quand même un certain une
certaine durée pour être apparu en
prenons l'exemple des syriens mais la
4e' mauvais exemple à une histoire qui
s'est mal terminée celle de sam hamad
sam hamad de représente quand même une
troisième génération syrienne double
double loyauté c'est un c'est encore une
espèce de mythe sur lequel il faudra à
un moment ou un autre se penser et
réfléchir mais on est aussi accusé de
double loyauté
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'un originaire
de france a dit cette génération ne
serait pas soupçonné de double loyauté
également qu'il ya des choses comme ça
dans les imaginaires ça traîne
oui je vois et que ça pèse mohamed je ne
suis pas d'accord mais tu es ma de ne
pas d'accord avec la question de loyauté
je préfère le thème appartenance
complémente l'immigration maghrébine
elle est bien importante
l'émigration est historiquement la
limitation maghrébine elle est bien
importante en europe ce qui fait que
l'europe elle fait partie du milieu
géopolitique des pays maghrébins qu'il
ya forcément l'intérêt économique qui a
forcément l'intérêt sécuritaire et ou
dans le cas du canada c'est différent le
canada ne fait pas partie du milieu
géopolitique du canada malheureusement
les échanges commerciales sont très
modestes et on en a besoin en fait des
activistes politiques qui sont actives
dans leur pays d'origine comme dans leur
pays d'accueil facettes ça facilite le
partage culturel
ça facilite le partage commercial ça
offre d'opportunités au canada comme aux
marques arabe et aussi de servir comme
un pont entre le canada et l'autre bout
de monde et l'autre bout du monde et le
canada j'ai dis toujours que comme j'ai
dit oui c'est important d'être impliqué
dans dans les deux pays et aussi d'avoir
le réseau dans les deux pays n'a qu'à
voir un bon réseau pour définir les
opportunités au canada là bas offrir
aussi les opportunités et partager aussi
un slogan que le gouvernement a levé que
canada est de retour dans le monde
le canada est de retour à travers les
ambassades du canada à travers les
canaux officiels mais à travers aussi on
peut on peut servir on peut les
immigrants peuvent jouer un rôle très
important dans la nouvelle diplomatie de
du canada comme aussi de partager les
dix filles du pays du maghreb qui ont
une influence quelque part aussi est
sûre sur les communautés maghrébines ici
donc je répète oui la loyauté la
question de loyauté oui on a le droit à
être loyal à notre pays d'accueil
personnellement je suis j'ai migré est
ici à l'âge de 19 ans mais j'ai étudié
dans les écoles de la tunisie j'ai été
soigné dans les hô pital de la tunisie
je suis reconnaissant et la
reconnaissance et une qualité
si on n'a pas de cette qualité là on ne
peut pas être ni reconnaissant à notre
notre pays d'accueil ni à notre pays
d'origine
donc là et pas peur de la politique
impliquez-vous c'est important la
politique c'est parmi les problèmes de
la communauté c'est la politique aussi
parce que il ya
il ya ceux qui qui moi je dis toujours
que ce que moi je vais aller vite fait
je dis pas qu'il ya je dis toujours
qu'il n'ya pas un projet contre la
communauté maghrébine et à notre projet
contre en faveur de la communauté
maghrébine ou en faveur de l'immigration
maghrébine au canada en fait il ya un
projet d'ouverture de diversité est un
projet aussi d'inclusion et un projet
d'exclusion désolation des messages de
haine et de peur de l'autre avec le
contexte international
ça rend un peu la communauté maghrébine
un peu plus fragile dans ce sens là mais
ça nous met aussi dans les premiers
rangs de cette lutte en faveur d'une
société diversifiée multiculturelle
ouverte
je voulais dit si on résout tous les
problèmes de la communauté maghrébine
aujourd'hui ceux qui son encontre contre
l'ouverture contre l'inclusion ils vont
s'attaquer à une autre minorité
donc la question c'est pas vraiment nous
on est un peu fragile due à un contexte
comme j'ai dit internationale mais leur
objectif c'est pas nous c'est vraiment
pas nous mais ça nous met dans cette
bataille là on est en fait en lutte pour
notre société canadienne pour la
diversité pour rendre pour que cette
pour que ce pays demeure un pays ouvert
inclusif
il ya beaucoup de travail finalement on
n'est pas une communauté victimes
on est une communauté qui est un peu
plus des défis on est une nouvelle
communauté une nouvelle on ait de
nouveaux migrants dans ce pays là c'est
normal connaissent ces défis là et on va
on va les avoir
je suis bien content qu'on ait débordé
les quelques minutes notre temps
d'antenne merci c'est fantastique et je
vais on a vu quoi double double loyauté
le mythe de la limite je sais le milieu
moko mohamed la porte devant le mythe de
la double appartenance mais en tout cas
c'est intéressant mais il ya aussi la
notion du double chapeau et tina c'est
petit c'est à vous qu'on termine et vous
je porter le chapeau d'une et
organisatrice du salon
vous allez vous adresser à la caméra je
sais pas laquelle numéro un deux ou
trois c'est là la seule au milieu voulu
adresser cette caméra firent des
internautes la montréal au québec qui
sont capables de se déplacer de venir au
salon d'ici demain pas se faire demain
dit leurs invités les alors vous invite
tous à la troisième édition du salon du
développement qu'elle a dù maghrébins au
palais des congrès de montréal
alors on vous attend en grand nombre
aujourd'hui jusqu'à 20 heures également
demain 2010 à 18h vous allez voir on a
beaucoup de surprises pour vous beaucoup
d'intervenants intéressant beaucoup de
plateau ça vaut vraiment la peine on
vous attends moi je voudrais vraiment
remercier à dellacherie c'est lui qui a
dit stéphane goethe organise les gens
autour de la teinture vas voir c'est
fantastique vous étiez de pas tous du
même avis heureusement et vous étiez
complémentaires par bien des aspects je
vous remercie infiniment de m'avoir
accueilli ici d'avoir accueilli radio
canada international ces deux randonnées
réplique on pourra l'année prochaine
s'il le faut alors autour de la table on
rappelle qu'ils étaient là tina ses
petits on l'applaudît
on applaudit chacune des personnes
myriam ou zaien d'arâches oui et puis -
edgar est bien sûr le grand patron de
mehdi tv abderrahim el habchi et notre
doyen du journalisme monsieur d'hadès
infiniment merci pour les informations
ici stéphane parent bon écoute sur radio
canada international et à la semaine
prochaine